[Music]
time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week antibiotic
resistance that's when drugs lose their
ability to stop an infection it's a
growing health problem in the US and
around the globe according to the
Centers for Disease Control and
estimated 2 million Americans deal with
antibiotic resistant infections every
year and 23,000 end up losing their
lives a new report from the CDC looked
specifically at unusual types of
antibiotic resistance here to talk about
that and more is CBS News medical
contributor dr. Tara
Andrew litera good morning good morning
Dana so they call this nightmare
bacteria what does that mean exactly it
doesn't sound good know that I know
these bacteria are predominantly
untreatable so resistant to most
antibiotics they tend to be uncommon and
they also can carry genes that can
spread resistance to other bacteria
they're a big problem for hospitals and
nursing facilities they have a very high
mortality rate and so in this study they
say they took about six thousand samples
25% of them carried those genes that
could be resistance genes that they
could pass on and interestingly when
they looked at asymptomatic contacts of
people who had had these infections 11%
of those also were carriers are
essentially colonized with these
superbugs so the CDC really said this
was way more than they expected in terms
of numbers and probably underestimates
the true number so it is pretty scary
the report highlights the CDC's
containment strategy what is it and is
it working so containment strategy not
really a new thing and essentially they
liken it to stopping a wildfire so the
idea is to catch these things when they
are a spark or a very small fire to
contain them to extinguish them before
they become a wildfire and it's very
difficult at that point and so it's
really five steps that they talk about
the first is rapid identification of
these infections and the mechanism that
makes them resistant going in and having
on-site infection control screening
those people around the infected person
to see who might be asymptomatic and
colonized and then basically continuing
to have a facilitated coordinated group
of people involving hospitals labs the
CDC all looking at this and staying on
top
it until they've stopped the spread one
of the issues is the antibiotics that
are prescribed also in the antibiotic
resistance so what role do doctors play
in all this in prescribing antibiotics
well we do play a big role and certainly
education is key and we know that still
today about 30% of antibiotic
prescriptions given out in offices and
ers are unnecessary of the 70% that are
necessary we can do a better job at
picking the right drug picking the
duration that we give that drug and the
dose and I think one of the things the
CDC mentioned in this report that's so
important for people to understand is
that these antibiotics they are what
they call a safety net for large groups
of people cancer patients patients in
the ICU surgical patients organ
transplant patients if they don't have
access to antibiotics because they are
have now resistance in these bacterias
this is a problem for those groups our
next topic three women all cancer
survivors are suing a Cleveland area
fertility clinic after the clinic
unintentionally destroyed more than
4,000 embryos and eggs
the lawsuit announced Monday is the
latest against the clinic Tara has been
closely following the story
losing my fertility was not an option
for me in an emotional press conference
the cancer survivors told similar and
painful stories I risked my life and
delayed my chemotherapy treatments
because him having a family was so
important to me Rachael Mel says when
she learned her eggs were gone it was
like a punch to the gut because of the
carelessness of uhf University Hospitals
I have now lost all hopes of ever having
biological children the new lawsuit
alleges University Hospitals did not
notify its clients or double check to
make sure it's local and remote
monitoring systems were functional
despite being aware of issues with the
liquid nitrogen storage tank in the
weeks preceding last month's malfunction
in a letter to patients last week
University Hospitals admitted the tank
in question needed preventive
maintenance prior to the March 3rd
incident the tanks that protect embryos
are often exempt from government
oversight but there are proposals in the
works for new regulations Ohio State
Senator Joe Schiavoni
is in the
early stages of crafting regulatory
legislation with fellow lawmakers if
something goes wrong with the chemical
makeup of this tank then there should be
a trigger
there should be alarm and there needs to
be somebody there that can remedy the
situation immediately but for some the
suggested regulations have come too late
you H must be held accountable for
shattering our dreams and for forever
altering the courses of each of our
lives University Hospitals responded to
Monday's press conference in a statement
saying we watched three women share
their stories of the loss they suffered
we are profoundly sorry for their loss
and are committed to helping make sure
this never happens again anywhere your
your heart just breaks for them what can
they do in the future to prevent this I
think the biggest thing is that it's
been really a Wild West and so the FDA
and states who need to step in and
provide regulation dr. taryn iruma thank
you